foreign
humor has always been a great coping
mechanism it's always been something
that's United us impressive that he's
been able to keep it a secret for so
long and this digital age of digital
sleuths I had no idea who it was it's a
cat with a Green Beret it's funny
[Music]
my name is Matt parish and for the last
three years I've been running one of the
biggest Special Forces meme Pages
anonymously on Instagram while also
being a special forces certain measure
uh at the beginning of covid in early
2020 everything was starting to shut
down and uh you know I I was following a
few of these military humor pages on
Instagram and uh you know it's fun
Community I thought there was a lot of
fun you know kind of back and forth and
I just decided on a whim one day I think
it was a Friday afternoon uh to start a
page right and there were so many
different pages popping up because
everybody had code you know everybody
was at home from covid or in different
uh places and uh so I just called it
another SF meme page because there were
a few right and so I was like hey here's
just another one I'll probably close it
by Sunday night or Monday uh and
ultimately I started really enjoying the
community started having some uh you
know some fun interaction with different
folks and realizing you know at that
point I had just come from 13 straight
years on a team and I was missing some
of that community and although I was in
this cool uh you know job as a first
sergeant and I had all these UH
responsibilities and all these great
people that I was working with I was
missing some of that team room Vibe of
you know every everybody kind of poking
fun at each other uh you know there's
there's really nothing sacred in one of
our team rooms you know there's a lot of
you know everybody's making fun of each
other and having fun I can remember so
many times in my career that you know
we're going through something terrible
or everything seems to just be sucking
you know it's raining it's terrible and
somebody makes just the right joke at
the right time that just turns your
spirits around right and so across the
military humor has always been a great
coping mechanism it's always been
something that's United us
and so about March of 2020 I had seen
some other uh communities some other
pages in different communities do these
sort of 64-page meme tournaments right
and so I said hey man that'd be cool for
our community and so I didn't tell
anybody I just started one made the
bracket tagged all 64 pages and said hey
we're doing this thing right and so I
didn't know if anybody would even take
me up on it and I just went after it and
all of a sudden it started just like
exploded right people were having so
much fun with it it was the perfect time
uh you know everybody needed a diversion
from covid a lot of people have more
time on their hands right and all of a
sudden we were getting millions of
Impressions on this little page that I
probably had four or five thousand
followers on at the time and so it was
uh it was all over the place in our
community and so about halfway through I
thought like how can I use this uh for
good like it's awesome that we're having
fun with it but like what else could we
do with it and I thought well maybe I
can raise some money for charity right
so I I read I kind of put out a couple
of stories saying like hey I'm getting
all these impressions of all this like
cool audience if any businesses would
like to quote unquote sponsor the
tournament
uh make a donation to either special ops
Warrior Foundation or Hunter 7
Foundation to uh two Charities and
non-profits that I really identified
with their missions so I said hey if you
donate to either one of those uh send me
a screenshot of the donation like no
money comes to me everything goes
straight to the charity and if you send
me a screenshot I'll kind of shout you
out as a thank you and that'll be quote
unquote sponsorship right and so I think
the first tournament we we raised you
know three thousand four thousand
dollars something like that it was
fairly small but it was out of nowhere
it was like hey cool we we raised a
couple thousand dollars I said hey maybe
we can do one for Halloween right so we
did the first halamim Madness uh
tournament kind of same deal a little
bit different uh you know Focus but we
raised like thirty thousand dollars for
charity for 107 Foundation at the time
the next March I think we raised like
fifty thousand dollars and then the next
October I think we raised like sixty
thousand dollars I can't relay how
thankful I am to Matt and to everybody
who supported the the meme tournament
you know whether it was five dollars or
five 500 you know your donation made a
difference in Saving Lives
one of the other amazing things that's
come out of this you know Meme page and
why I've kept it around is I've had a
lot of opportunity to counsel people
people have been more willing to come
and talk to me as an anonymous meeting
page where people would come to me and
say like hey I don't know who you are
but I like I don't know who else I would
talk to about this like are you willing
to talk to me about you know I'm having
substance abuse issues or I'm having uh
issues with PTSD and mental health care
I started being able to witness to
people and counsel them and all of a
sudden I had people that you know were
coming back and saying hey I just got
out of Inpatient Rehab I went and took
care of my substance abuse thing and a
lot of it was because some of the
conversations we had or hey I just got
baptized and and saved and it was you
know as a result of you know me opening
up to those things because of some of
the conversations and some of the memes
and different things in the in the
direct messages or hey I was willing to
raise my hand and go get help and go see
a psych and start working through some
of the things and now my marriage is
doing better or I'm doing better at work
and so every time I started to kind of
say like okay that's enough of this page
I'm going to shut it down like it takes
a lot of time and all this other stuff
something would happen like that where
uh you know I would get this report back
from somebody where it had made an
impact and uh it was just incredible so
to me it was like okay God's given me
this uh this opportunity this influence
opportunity
that I would have never thought I'd have
and so like let's use it let's use it
for good
as a leader I was I had a better finger
on the pulse of some of the things
happening down in the like again I was
in charge of like a global organization
and I was learning things at different
places that I wouldn't have known as the
senior enlisted leader because of like
span of control but some E5 in Ranger
regiment would text me and be like yo I
uh you know whatever you just be talking
about something I'd be like oh that's
interesting and I would go and try to
fix that problem
up until a couple of months ago my wife
was the only one who knew that I was
running this page I didn't tell even my
closest friends any of that stuff for a
couple of reasons the main one was that
as a senior enlisted leader as an E9 in
an organization and having a global
reach I didn't want it to become a
distraction I never thought it would
have been
um but it makes it makes sense now but I
know Matt on a professional capacity you
know I've done a podcast with him on
softcast I've done presentations where
he's been in attendance and you know
he's an E9 and so me and my E5 I was
like you know he's very serious very
Stern started major you know
um but once I once I really sat down and
got to know him he's he's a hell of a
guy
parish is a force to be reckoned with so
that's why we're thrilled to have him as
the host and the producer of this rubric
Foundation podcast prep for impact
because quite frankly I could not think
of a better person in this community to
lead that that effort
terms on our
arguing that he had this meme page and
then he he said oh I should tell you and
he he informed me that he was behind
this and and I had seen the meme page uh
and and followed it since joining the
organization and would oftentimes laugh
at what I was seeing and he said do you
think that that's an issue I said
actually I think if anything it's it's a
it's a massive addition to to kind of
the notoriety of who you are and and
once you Avail yourself to the community
I am a firm believer that laughter cures
a lot of challenges in life
Matt's sense of humor is
um spot on with how we should go about
navigating our life and looking at uh
life as the glasses half full opposed to
half empty and kind of laughing through
the challenges at times that you have
also very uh impressive that he's been
able to keep it a secret for so long A
lot of times people were more willing to
talk to me
um by the fact that I was Anonymous and
it's one of the things that I hope I
don't lose by now being open about it
being me but I also know that there are
a lot of people who fake who they are
um when they're Anonymous right and
there's always been across the community
anybody who's completely Anonymous
there's always been like uh hey is this
person really a Green Beret are they
really a ranger are they really who they
say they are or are they just somebody
who's using that and uh you know so I
certainly don't it's not something I
want like any sort of really
you know any sort of fame or anything
like I'm not looking for anything out of
it I just think it's an opportunity now
that I've now that I'm retired I want to
use the page for good I want to continue
to use it to raise charity raise
awareness or raise money for charity
raise awareness for these causes and now
with starting my own podcast I want to
be able to broaden the discussion on
some of those things right like I want
to be able to have a conversation that's
very impactful as a podcast and then
share some memes about it to you know
kind of generate thought and further
discussion I want to be able to carry
you know things that people find
interesting about some of the podcast
episodes I want to be able to have
conversations about that on social media
and rather than uh you know try to do it
super anonymously it just sort of seems
like hey let's uh let's put it out there
so that way people know hey I am a real
Green Beret I have been married for over
16 years I've got kids I've had to go
through a ton of ups and downs I've had
a ton of injuries over the course of my
career I've had to seek mental health
care myself for PTSD and things like
that you know all of these things that I
want people to know like hey it's legit
it's authentic it is real and uh you
know I care about you know making an
impact in our community
[Music]